after years of developing games across
ps2 ps3 and ps4 evolution studios has
been shut down by Sony according to a
statement issued a game spot the closure
was enacted as part of a restructure to
its European studios regular reviews
take place throughout SCE worldwide
studios ensuring that the resources that
we have in such a competitive landscape
can create and produce high quality
innovative and commercially viable
projects as part of this process we've
reviewed and assessed all current
projects and plans for the short and
medium term and have decided to make
some changes to the European studio
structure it's been decided that
evolution studios will close Sony said
it will attempt to shift some developers
from evolution studios which is also
known for its work on the world rally
championship and motorstorm franchises
to other teams it noted however that
there will be some compulsory
redundancies Paul rust shinsky director
of driveclub posted a message addressing
the closure on Twitter before I sign off
to take a break and spend some time with
my family I just wanted to say a few
words he said firstly a big thank you to
all the fans that supported us
throughout evo storied history we
couldn't have achieved what we did
without you thank you to Sony who helped
evo rise to the top tier of racing game
teams in the world working as a
first-party team has been a fantastic
experience last but certainly not least
a massive thank you to the whole team at
evo it truly has been an honor to work
with such a talented passionate and
determined group of people I hope you'll
all join me in celebrating evolution by
picking up a pad throwing on your
favorite evo game and giving us a
victory lap if you're curious about the
fate of driveclub the racing sim will be
supported by other PlayStation teams our
thoughts go out to those who may have
lost their jobs